είνα φυννοτς κυρές και προ σταάτομα που εμπλέκονται αλλά και για να δίννεται κ ένα
ξεκάθαρομήνμα μιδενικής ανοχή στον οποιονδήποτε ενδέχεται ανασκεφτίποτησε να κάνε κάπι τις βάρος του δημόσιου φερονάσι
να λλάξουμε θέμα θεωρίς ότι το κράτος σήμερα δίνει θα κίνητρα από πρέπει στους νέους
ώστε να σχοληθούμε τη γεωργία θεωρό ότι σήμερα μέσων και τις κινής αγρωτικής πολιτικής μενα
φακελλο πέραν των τετραβοτίουν πενήντα εκατομυρίων ευρό δίνονται πάρακολλ κινήτα εμείς αυτόν το οποίο εκάμαμε
είναι ότικαταρτήσαμε τις στρατηγική για των πρωτογεντομέαν και τούτι οι στρατηγική δεν έγινε ν από
πάνω προς τακάτω κατευικάμε στων κόσμο εμιλήσα με τους αγρότες και ο τις αγρότησες ίπαμμα
στι χρειάζονται επείαμε στος ακαδειγμαϊκούς επείαμε στους εξιδικευμένος ανθρώπους που έχωυ γνώσ επείαμε στις αγρωτικές
οργανώσεις ρωτήσαμε τους τεχνοκράτες κι έγεινε μια ολόκληρη στρατηγική που έχει ώς πρώτερεότηταν της να
κάνει ελκιστικών των πρωτοαγενιτομέα και να αναδείξει και την επαγγελματική γεοργία ο πρωτογενίς τουμε συναι
πάραβολλα της κοριώς ο αγρώτης και αυρώότης έχουν πραγματικά δύσκολη καθημερινότητα ενα ένανα βέβαιον περιβαλλο
να βέβαιον πλαίσιων δεελδεξερις πως θα είναι οι καιρικές συνθήκες άρα μετούτη τις στρατηγική εμείς
τη προσπαθούμε να κάνουμε να κάουμε ερτιστικών οπως είπα των πρωτογενήντομέα να δώσουμε χρηματοδοτικά κίνητρα
κε δυνατότητας τους γεωργούς να αποκτήσουν τις υποδομές πτους θα τους δώσουν α απεξάρτηση που
τις κυρικές συθήκες μείο συνερού εξικαι και ηδυνατότι ήταν πρόσφασης στην τεχνολοϊγία και στην έξυπνη
γεοεργία ο στόχος μας είναι να μεγαλώσει ο πρωτογενις στομέας να είναι οπως υπα διώσιμος
σ